the co-host of UFC tonight every
Wednesday at 8 p.m. Eastern Time on fs1
former MMA fighter and co-host of
science at Discovery Channel's
BattleBots
none other than Kenny Florian how are
you sir I'm doing great crazy weekend a
little bit you think
yeah I guess so my first question for
you just opening up at large yes
what do you think of that you know it
was crazy it was definitely crazy but I
don't think we should be so shocked
right I mean when emotions are running
high we see this in football basketball
soccer you know these guys are fighters
they've been honing these skills for
years they've been training themselves
to respond with violence in a certain
way for a long time and this is a guy in
Habib nurmagomedov who is from Dagestan
which is one of the more dangerous
places in Europe and you know they've
been producing some of the best
wrestlers in Russia for a very long time
they are a pride people prideful people
you know that they definitely respect
their own their culture and religion and
other people's religion for the most
part and you know like if you're talking
about all those sensitive issues they're
not gonna be cool with wise and yeah I
said something similar at the top of the
program about that Kenny again that you
know how are we shocked that somebody
who goes in to an octagon and accepts
the punishment like that who wrestles a
bear from Dagestan exactly when he's
seven how dare this person not act
professionally when it's all over
because to me though that touches upon
the fault line of this sport being this
Dana White and UFC wants to be taken
seriously professionally as a
professional sports league yes a
professional sport and Steve Austin
tweeted something out after the fight
that I think kind of poked the bear for
you a little bit saying I love
professional wrestling is what he said
and to me that is what to see that sort
of mayhem happen after the fight kind of
touches on the fault line Dana White's
trying to avoid at UFC absolutely
endless than if this happened you know
maybe 10 to 15 years ago
you know it would be really bad but I
think we have established ourselves as a
legitimate professional sport and I
think one of the main one of the main
issues for for a promoter is maybe not
making you know the right fights all the
time but it's identifying the right
storyline right to make the fight I
think that is what precedes making the
right fight and we have another great
storyline you know to be honest and
listen for a lot of people you know
Habib it has been one of those guys who
has had a really bad style for Conor
McGregor the fact that Conor McGregor
came back after being two years away
from the sport and fought the worst
style matchup for him in the UFC says a
lot and I think that he could probably
do better if there's a lot of
adjustments he needs to make Habib will
always be it's a bad style matchup form
but we do have a great storyline both
these guys are polar opposites as far as
their approaches in the Octagon they
still have that bad blood and I think a
lot of people would want to see a
rematch so at that and I know again just
to repeat what I said it at the top of
the show that we're all gonna get there
we're all we're all gonna get there to
this rematch everybody do you know why
it's gonna get there phoebs gonna get
there Connors gonna get there every
because there's way too much money and
interest to get there but I'm just glad
again that dana white is showing the
proper emotion of contrition for at
least for me yes other fire other other
fight fans might be like own it Dana
just own it that this board is brutal
that people you know are our animal in
nature and you just go for it I'm just
I'm glad at least for for me as a sports
fan right that this is not proper
behavior somebody could have really
gotten hurt what was it doubt well then
the reality is is you know in no way am
I making an excuse for it these guys are
fighters this is something that is very
rare in this sport you know tensions
were running high not only between the
fighters but between the camps their
honor go too far
yeah I mean you could definitely argue
that right I mean listen this fight
ended the way it began right it started
with the dolly being thrown at the bus
that's how this fight got put together
so I guess we shouldn't be so shocked
and surprised that this fight kind of
ended in this manner if they were not
gonna be cool with that
and yeah he might have gone too far now
if this rematch does happen what's he
gonna say to lead you know and the
lead-up to this fight I he'll will
probably stay away from you know the
cultural references and their religious
references and any should I think that
was a little bit too far but you know uh
I think he's still gonna spit a lot of
venom in the lead-up to the rematch I
guess that's what people expect of him
and he was also seen in footage after
the fight throwing a punch at Habib's
manager I mean it's just you know it's
just it's crazy that that dolly and the
bus is one thing mm-hmm because that's
just people on a bus sure and I actually
I know it's it they're both particularly
bad one got Connor arrested in New York
City okay mm-hmm the bus here was a
whole bunch of paying customers
yeah and Habib's dolly was his fist yeah
and his body just being thrown in his
like a missile into the into the crowd
right and again so so here we are Kenny
Florian here on the Rich Eisen show
we've spent just several minutes talking
about this what about the fight itself
because if this didn't happen we would
be talking about McGregor on his ass or
arse right on the you know in in the
fourth round yes and and what Habib did
to him so what what did he do
yeah so listen you know I think first of
all the fact that it was a pretty good
fight I mean the way I saw it and the
way a lot of people saw it it was either
gonna be Connor early with the knockout
or is gonna be Habib late with a TKO or
submission and obviously it went the way
of Habib and Habib was able to take him
down repeatedly control him like he's
done to so many other opponents and
khabib has become the bear that he's
trained with as a kid
he really has he this come the bear
that's what he that's what he does he
takes you down and he malls you he gets
you in a compromising position and he
takes you out either with his fists or
the submission and that's what he did
against Connor
I thought Connor won the third round I
thought he was able to stop a couple of
those takedowns keep it on the feet land
some shots it wasn't the most impressive
round but still that is the first round
and Habib nurmagomedov has ever lost in
his whole professional mixed martial
arts square that's how dominant he has
been and he's done it with a style that
you know exactly what he's gonna do and
he still can't stop him it's a style
that a lot of American wrestlers used in
the late 90s early 2000s and that was
kind of like an antiquated style that a
lot of people say you can't use that
anymore you can't just come in here with
one style and beat everybody khabib
nurmagomedov is doing this in 2018 you
know what he's gonna do you can't stop a
me takes you down he beats you up he
controls you it's a very tiring style to
deal with it really is so could you say
he's the best of all time could you call
him a goat right now I mean where do you
see just dismantled Conor McGregor just
the fact that he went you know price of
all right against Conor McGregor it's
the fact that he hasn't lost and he
hasn't lost a round is simply amazing
he's 27 and oh now you look at all the
guys that Connor has beaten I always saw
it when I was fighting that anytime I
had an opportunity to beat someone I
have the opportunity to take everything
that they've ever accomplished in their
sport you know that they've done and
Habib has done that against Conor who
has beaten some fantastic competition
and Habib proved himself to absolutely
be one at one of the best no doubt about
and how long did it take you to calm
down after fun I mean cuz they're really
cause again I cannot imagine how you
must transform yourself from a regular
normal human being yeah part of society
yes and then have to get yourself ready
to get in that octagon I was talking
about to say they're dead there were
many fights where when I did fight I
didn't sleep for a very long time or it
didn't sleep until morning because your
Adrenaline's going crazy your energy is
still your buzzing it's it's an
emotional thing it's a it's a thing that
you train many months for many years for
when you win or you lose you're still
kind of taking it all in and you know
habib has never been a part of a huge
event like that Conner has been a part
of a huge fight so obviously but
mayweather won was historic habib had
never been part of a spectacle like that
and i think you know he let his emotions
get the better of and that overshadowed
the bout itself right which overshadowed
together to me burying the lede of UFC
229 which was the post match interview
between Derrick Lewis and Joe Rogan oh
my gosh reviewing and listening audience
of the Rich Eisen show if you have not
seen this put the kids away okay make
sure you're in a locked room turn the
volume up on this interview and what
he's from Houston Texas he has one of
the funniest instagrams ever he always
posts funny videos he's got a great
sense of humor and he's not Rogan
closing interviewing that your Instagram
is with the greatest yeah he's amazing
and he sees a huge man he's a guy who's
always capable winning the fight in an
instant with one shot he was losing that
fight he was losing the whole fight
against an excellent fighter from Russia
and Volkoff and he came back to win in
the final seconds of the fight it was
amazing I was really happy for Derek and
uh
and do you normally take your pants off
and in celebration that is not - that is
not typical that is not
but I'm not a heavyweight so I don't
know you don't know very good all right
so before we we go what do you think the
aftermath is here we're all hearing Dana
White saying that a title could be
stripped checks might not be delivered
Conor McGregor has not pressed charges
which to me I think is proof that there
he wants the rematch it's already
tweeted about it because I know is how
difficult it was this this fight was to
set up because of his own legal problems
because of the dahle being threatened
yes yeah so what do you think happens
here well again it's one thing throwing
the dahle on the bus it's outside you
know outside of a fight this will happen
during a fight that was overseen by the
Nevada State Athletic Commission and
they're probably not going to tolerate
something like this so I would imagine
some kind of hefty fine is gonna be
levied at habib and his team and and
perhaps at Conner as well you do see
Connor hitting one of the members of a
Bebe's team who was coming over to
actually fight him so in a way he was
defending himself I'm not saying that he
was in the right at all both teams were
at fault here but I don't think
stripping the belt is necessary I think
habib should keep the belt i do think
there were probably some kind of find
there and and again i was talking about
emotions running high this is something
i'm not shocked about but at the same
time if you're going to do that you have
to also be prepared for the
repercussions and I'm sure he he'll be
paying some kind of a check okay
and then just because we won't hold you
to it and if you're wrong you're wrong
yeah just throw a dart at a board and
give me a date for the rematch oh okay
I'm you date for the rematch when you
think is it this year no it won't be
this year so it's possible it's pokémon
I'll put it together for Jen one that
would be amazing yeah they might they
might have got it they got it they gotta
pull back a little bit here it's
possible they have a main event I think
scheduled already probably for the end
of the year for the New Year's card but
I mean crazier things have happened
if they want to let this thing simmer a
little marinate marinate a little bit I
think next year early early next year
February let's go with that that works
out 19 get your tickets now Wow Kenny
thanks for coming
thank you you got a Kenny Florian again
co-host of science and Discovery
Channel's BattleBots with the good ol
Chris Rose yes sir
who's living and dying with his Browns
every single day and his Indians on the
verge of elimination and co-host of UFC
tonight every Wednesday at 8 p.m.
Eastern Tom Kenny Florian here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience